welcome back to our studio here at the
floor at the ftth Congress in Stockholm
the world's largest fiber-to-the-home
convention in the world of course beside
me I have a good newark mark Swedish man
member of the European Parliament
working really hard for
fiber-to-the-home fiber to Europe you
tell me more about your visions well my
my vision is and that sounds rather
simple I think Europe should be the best
connected continent in the world with
the best piece and the highest
capacities and the reason for that is
very simple if you have that then your
society in your economy will be the
leading one there is no single
investment in the future that is more
satirical than being best regarding
internet and broadband capacities it
doesn't seem very clear for everybody in
the world we saw last year nearly cruz
didn't give the telecom business that
much money for fiber as they wanted but
why is it so hard to to get get there
with this message well first of all it's
not in fact on a matter of public
funding is a matter of the private
funding and in that sense I think we can
see a number of successful regions of
Europe berm and some that are less
successful but the important thing is
wherever you do it wherever you invest
overall it's extremely profitable
industry that is also profitable for the
society because it is increasing the
amount of jobs by competitiveness by
efficiency and by creating the scope of
new businesses new markets the new ideas
new services this is the most dynamic
sector of our societies and they're
influencing the society as a whole but
if
is it going slow or is it going fast the
rollout of I don't know about I don't
know because I think you can say both of
it it's going slow slow in some parts of
Europe and rather rapid in other parts
but but I think what you really can say
it is whatever is going still too slow
because if we are to be the best we need
to be better than all the others and I
think a problem for a lot of Europeans
and this is not only by telecom we are
comparing too much with our past and
with our self and we were forgetting
that we are leaving in a globalized
world and in Africa mobile telephoning
is increasing rapidly in Asia you have
countries like South Korea Japan and
China who are advancing all the time in
us with a 4g generation you have a
number of developments and if we are to
match this we have to be decisive and I
can't see in a reason for not being
decisive so how could we get there I
think it is very much people in the
industry the ITC industry in the telecom
industry they need to be more self
confident in the sense that they are not
what they are talking about their
businesses they are not talking all
about their businesses they are talking
about ours our society can improve and
develop our the logic of all sectors of
our economy and well firm can develop so
to be less technical and be more
societal politicians need to see not
only the ambitions and divisions but
also the means and the decisions you
need to take and to create a link
between what you want and what you need
to do and and in our society as a whole
will need to increase the awareness of
the opportunities where there's a
election year election in the EU this
year is the the question about broadband
anything which is on the agenda out
there in in the sense that the whole
telecom issue is important
but I think that a a good thing that
also is a problem as it sometimes the
case is that everyone agrees that we
need to improve so there is no
difference on that and that's good but
that makes also maybe the discussion a
little bit to detail or difficult to see
the the pattern of because there are
differences if we are to go for the high
ambitions if you are to secure that our
attractive investments if you are using
the internal market open up the internal
market for the digital economy then all
the investments will be much more easy
to to degrade so I think there are huge
political differences in the view of how
to deregulate how to open up the markets
where people and I as I and others are
extremely Pro Open hang up the European
market opening up our borders and
securing that we can be in the lead
regarding the the internet and this
election will have substantial
importance for the outcome in the future
so what's the best case on what's the
worst case of the outcome I think the
worst case is if we are entering a
period of believe in public spending
that is making a situation where we'll
have less of private investments in
Europe the worst outcome could be if we
are getting into face of more
regulations in all areas more
bureaucracy if I might be frank my
socialist opponents in every issue like
this and others are always claiming that
we can solve the problems with higher
public spending and more regulations I
do not share that view I do share that
we need to get more room for the human
factor in the videos of Europe so we're
in Sweden now when it comes to fiber and
broadband Sweden is a country which many
countries are looking at are you proud
to be here and show show up sweden for
the rest of the broadband europe and
actually the world we have people from
84 entries here
as I'm proud and I think is a fantastic
amazing thing that the ftth has arranged
this event here in Stockholm is there's
a good opportunity for star coma for
Sweden to show but it's also good
inspiration for us to understand that
also in other countries in the world
people are moving ahead and I think this
is not the time to be self-confident too
much we shall be proud of what we
achieved that we must also be tempted
about what we can do in the future so
Sweden has a has more to do we have more
to do because world is changing I wrote
earlier about today about the risk for
believing in the snapshots oh yeah you
know when you take a snapshot you see
something that is it might be a nice
dancer up rotating yeah but the
snapshots gives you a very short view
you don't know if he or she are is
falling down or where she'll be in the
next half seconds and that's also the
same thing for the ICT sector is moving
very rapidly and if we don't press ahead
all the time we will be lagging behind
the best today risk being lagging behind
if we're not trying to be best tomorrow
and that Cray requires efforts decisions
and visions order any specific countries
in Europe that does that are developing
very well when it comes to these these
kinds of strategies you think I think
overall the Nordic countries are
developing world and which is a paradox
because you could say that there are not
having the same level of population as a
lot of other countries but the Nordic
countries have been moving ahead very
well and I'm happy about that of course
but I will be even more happier if all
the rest of the continent were moving
ahead false because regarding internet
the old room the more the merrier is
very true and I think it will be an
extremely good thing for European
economy and the European market in
European economy if all member states
were moving ahead
faster and we all move faster are there
any good examples like except for the
Nordics that that are moving ahead and
doing a good job when it comes to as I
understand it but this is always
difficult to point i think the
netherlands are moving ahead well i
think in luxembourg which is a small
country it may be easier it's a good
thing estonia latvia has made a huge
achievement not least estonia because
Estonia is one of the most computerized
countries their government was first to
deal with computers not documents in the
paper so I think we can look around and
find good examples all of us yeah you
had a speech earlier today as you
mentioned you talked about the snapshots
were there anything else specific just
talked about that that well I I
mentioned one thing that I'm coming back
to you ladies away when we're talking
about space and capacities that will be
essential for the services of tomorrow
because the services of today wouldn't
have been possible with the speeds in
capacities of yesterday I wouldn't have
been possible no and if we want them to
be developing here and not somewhere
else we need to have the capacities in
the speed so tomorrow if we are to have
the services of tomorrow yeah so we need
to see that if we are not expanding our
ambitions it will not be possible to
expand the innovations and the growth in
Europe but it seems to me like you're
talking very much about speed and I
guess the gasoline and capacity today
it's only a few people that actually can
get the high speeds but when we talk at
least about Sweden Sweden is a huge
country and when we come out in the
rural areas it's very hard what so what
are your opinion about the rural areas
where should we put the limits for them
what internet speeds I think we should
have as an overall requirement that
hungry megabits for those who follow
this it's much more than we have today
but it will be relevant in the years to
come I think that should be the bottom
level and which you can reach via 4G
and you will do it by a 5g in the future
and you can also reach it via other way
so it's not only a matter of living in
cities and town towns but I do also
think this implies that we need to press
on and combine the infrastructure of
fiber optics you know optic fibers with
other infrastructures we need to do some
digging in order to be more empowered as
a nation yeah so have you been been
around at the event and looking well
have you seen anything specific no I
think that one of the themes that you
can think about is that if you were
visiting Congress like this ten years
ago it would have been European and
American brands dominating now we have a
lot of Asian names that gives a sign on
the change in a in a greater sense it
soon it's a big picture and it means
that we have competition from everywhere
we have who I together with Ericsson
which is on their home street here and
and you can see the same pattern it's a
market and a society that is expanding
very much and you can see that it's not
only technology anymore it's all the
services and all the ways how to develop
and distribute the services that is
about it's quite amazing it's umm I'm
happy to have the opportunity to be here
we are very happy to have had you here
for this interview gonna thank you very
much for coming thank you thank you and
as I've said earlier we're on the in the
middle of the floor of the exhibition
hall and we are sending here live and
besides of this stream we have three
different streams talking straight from
the seminars where you can follow and if
you want to register and hear more about
to see more from the seminars you just
register at FTTH conference dot EU and
with me now I have Nadia
with work who's been working really hard
for this conference indeed indeed I have
I'm feeling every happy and also very
tired but I think this event has been a
very very nice so far and we have a lot
of delegates who walk around with smile
so I'm happy when did you start to plan
for Stockholm oh we start to plan a long
time ago I would say more than a year
ago basically we need to already have
decided where we are going the next year
before we have the events so for example
I know already now that we are going to
be in warsaw in 2015 and so several
months ago i started already going there
to visit some venues and meet some some
people so it's a long yeah it's a long
lasting work overtime which picks up
with the with the HDH conference yeah
interesting and it's really fun to have
all of you here in stock on which is my
hometown so you had a press conference
yesterday indeed yes yes we didn't
actually it's a good thing that you are
mentioning is Sweden you know as your
home country because there's a link also
to what we announced in the press
conference yesterday we invite it is the
tradition that we invite journalists to
the 80 th conference and a lot of them
come because we announce every year in
February the ranking of the countries
that have more than one percent
penetration of their households
connected as subscribers to fibre to the
home of vibe to the building and that's
what we announced yesterday and Sweden
is in second position in second position
only yes everybody who's been in the
studio has said Sweden his best yes well
I think Sweden is a historic leader so I
think Sweden was number one a long time
ago but actually the number one now is
Lithuania yes with about thirty five
percent penetration and Sweden you know
with about twenty six percent
penetration now
but still number one in Europe and there
are not many countries that have more
than twenty percent penetration so it's
it's really great and I think what we
see in Sweden that we cannot see
Lithuania yet for examples that because
it's in Sweden ftth was deployed already
a long time ago so we have the hind
sight to see already now the services
that are FTTH enabled and that you can
actually see all around here in the
event we have walls of applications dome
with some demos inside that's the you
know the gaming industry's is a very big
industry in Sweden so it's nice to be
here and this is the reason we came to
suck on is that really we can show some
real stuff what are the end users
actually doing with the bandwidth and
this is a yeah the place to do that yeah
what has been the best services to
showcase services you we have been seen
here and actually it's yet to come in a
session this afternoon I think I mean
the one that I find the you know the
it's a fun service that is in the e care
industry so it's all we talk about care
though yes you're talking and monitoring
of elderly people or chronically sick
patients it's called giraffe and it's a
monitored device that actually follows
the person around the home and on the
other other and on a computer it's like
a Skype on wheels so you know you could
the the person stays at home and can be
communicating with family doctors nurses
anybody could be on a computer just
calling in to this moving screen so it's
like a companion also for the people who
are sick but who do not need to be in a
hospital and they will be speaking this
afternoon in one of the conference
sessions yeah but we have a lot of other
demos of course in for example the
entertainment industry you know I talked
about gaming but also of course although
as long as this video involved you need
a lot of bandwidth and you know you need
for the interactivity bandwidth also up
going up so not just in the downlink but
also in the uplink that is something
that would fiber to the home
you can really you know get some some
nice interactivity there's applications
also in the you know we're talking about
the connected objects in the home you
know and that is also for full on demo
here yeah lots of stuff yeah you brought
with your computer with the 50 hey yes
it's basically just it's just a ranking
so I said that we announced yesterday in
the press conference the European
ranking yeah and this is based on the
market panorama which is prepared by e
dot analyst firm and you're actually
interviewing others NT they're coming to
send you off to you don't really too
much down exactly you you will ask him
all the questions you want about that
but just what questions should i ask you
down i should ask him all the questions
no just maybe giving you an overview so
you see visually what I was talking
about on the penetration rate which you
see is a real nice guy but you you see
of course some countries are still below
that the first line is five percent so
this first line here is five percent and
you see that there are still quite a lot
of countries here including actually
eu28 which means the average of the
European Union is actually below five
percent penetration of five to the home
so you Swedes don't realize this but the
rest of Europe you know there's a lot of
people who are no that's what I for did
yet except except from Russia it's very
small countries we're talking about
hairalyssa Aranea Sweden is a very very
very large country if you ask me but at
least Geographic large but we have a
very few people or 9 million people or
something latvia norway bulgaria
slovakia denmark it's quite small
countries yes the larger countries like
france is in the ranking and you know
going up slowly but for example germany
and the UK there are missing from the
ranking which means in those countries
there is actually less than one percent
of the people who are connected to fog
to the home why
they have made the choice of some other
technologies which of course are based
on fiber but fiber far away from the
Angie's are which we do not recommend
because the closer the fiber is so
that's why we promote 50 people will my
people would like to have fiber all the
way yes because the further the fiber of
the more people you share it with hands
you know the Lord for speed and and the
quality of service and everything you're
losing the further away it is so those
in those countries the operators have
made the choice of pushing back the date
when they will have to deploy five to
the home because they know that they
will have to do it but for now it is not
the choice that they have made yeah no
yeah this is the for you it's the third
day of conference for most of us owners
it's the second day of conference have
you been around out you have I have
indeed is there anything specific you
one specific thing you would point I
would like to point out for for the
guests and the viewers and see I think
what's really I would like the viewers
to see is the services from from Sweden
the ftth enabled services and
applications because I think we have the
chance to be here it stuck on this year
and the conference changes every year we
go from one country to the next so this
is really the opportunity and we are
actually calling the baseline of the
conference is showcasing a brighter
future future so it is a showcase so let
people enjoy you know go to the sessions
where there are some Swedish people
presenting their services the innovation
is amazing so that's what I would
encourage people to do thank you very
much for coming thank you mad and as you
can see we're still on the floor here in
the exhibition hall sending straight to
you out on the web costs and we're
talking about what's happening here on
this place where almost all important
people within the ftth an FTT be
business are hanging around discussing
listening
and everything and with me now I have
two new guests I have a gram fini scream
fini where are you from luggage you're
from London and what company from heavy
reading heavy reading that's sorry it
seemed closer come closer and then we
have Roland montage hi from France and
directly I date or let's say e dot e dot
I did sounds much funnier for me Roland
you you did this research from what we
saw the numbers right here is there
anything more specific we can say about
the research the results of the research
we heard at Sweden number two are we
climbing or are we falling or are we
stable well indeed we are very in order
to do this research again the CFO for
the council our goal is ready to measure
exactly the fiber to the home fiber to
the building a whole out so we have
different angles when you are looking at
those statistic if we look first at the
global you what we call the global
Europe with 39 countries so it's
including countries such as Russia
Ukraine you know when you look at this
you have a 20 million subscribers it's
quite a lot but among those 20 million
subscribers 10 million subscribers are
only in the Russia or Ukraine so this
part of large Europe is very impressed
if you compare to the political Europe
we have less than 8 million Europe the
au 28 8 million subscriber so dynamics
volumes are different but dynamics are
here also in the political Europe but
there must be a reason why the Russians
also good and digging fiber you know in
in Russia most of the people are living
in large buildings in large md use and
when looking at the business model of
fiber to the home it's less costly to
deploy in a big MDU in a big building so
this is part of the explanation also of
the success of over to Domino sure and
also the bad quality of copper because
people
did not experience until then great
quality as it is the case in Western
Europe with adsl so they are rushing to
fiber to the home oh yeah Graham you're
looking into the future hmm will the
Russians Vitas even yes the future well
having you harder than us there is a big
country so enemies defined partly where
they are at the moment what they're
planning to do and how large the country
is and Russia you know by virtually the
fact it's the largest country in Europe
that we're looking at it's going to
continue to be the number one country by
far it will reduce a little bit in terms
of it's sort of domination of the
figures that we're presenting it's about
forty five percent now and it's going to
be something like thirty three percent
in 2018 that's what we're forecasting so
it won't be quite as dominant to country
other countries like France and Spain
will start to become more significant
because they have big build out programs
and there are also relatively large
countries but what other countries will
grow fast do you think well I mean the
countries at the bottom are going to
grow the fastest in the sense that they
have very little at the moment so I mean
some countries like Germany will
probably grow quite fast from where they
are but there is a very very low base I
mean they've got very little FTTH at the
moment right and there there are not
they don't seem to be invested very much
into fiber I'm sorry to say no I mean
the Deutsche Telekom is not really
interested in FTTH at the moment so the
only players who are building our city
networks and they're quite patty I mean
they're only operating in certain cities
so in Germany as a whole a lot of cities
are not having any FTTH deployed so how
have you done all this research it must
be huge work just to get these number
collected well at that we have the
chance to work for the council for years
a Europe and outside Europe also so we
have a culture to have direct contact
with the players we are really a button
up approach asking player by player what
are you doing in terms of technology in
terms of services in terms of hole out
so it is most of
of the time they had contact and of
course we are always cross-checking the
validation of the data with members of
the fth console your browser vendors
helping us to check and recheck the
validity of the data oh yeah and you're
doing the forecast that seems to be
there either it's the trickier part or
it's the easier part depends on how well
you can talk of course you could yeah I
mean we take a lot of factors into
account I mean we start our starting
point is the data which edike collects
the council asked us to use that data in
order to create consistency but
obviously we die our own scan of what's
going on and we're mainly focused on
what they say they're going to do in the
future so you know the biggest input
into the forecast is what operators what
stage of operators reach how many homes
that they passed what do they say
they're going to do in future hand quite
importantly have they delivered on what
they said they were going to deliver in
the past because a lot of operation of
announced plans and then far far behind
what their original schedule was like
for example the operators in France so
we have to take that into account and
say you know do we think this is
realistic and then there are some larger
sort of macro issues such as you know
are there applications which justify
FTTH which mean that the operation will
be compelled to go towards ftth what
else is happening you know there are new
technologies on the copper side like
vectoring which allow people who have
got copper based networks to get to
higher speed and might delay them going
to FTTH it will take factors like that
into account so there's a long list of
things that we take into account and
like Roland we're looking at it bottom
up and looking at each operator in
saying you know how far realistically
can we expect them to get by 2018 is
this a market still is still ruled by
the operators or is it the demand from
the customers which is ruling the
rollout and the ruling the well in terms
of players deploying fibre-to-the-home
we have several category of players we
have of course incumbents operated by
the way the dynamic has been
accelerating because this year we have a
15
increment operator in Europe deploying
fiber there was only ten last year but
the main players deploying fiber to the
home is more alternative operators and
some couple guys putting fiber 22 to the
building we have to mention this and
finally and here in Sedona is really the
land of local authorities deployment
cities and regions it's also more and
more players involved in the deployment
especially outside of the euro banaras
when we are looking model rural sites um
yeah yeah and you we also have all these
people going out digging themselves here
in Sweden it's it's quite unfamiliar
from your part of Europe ideas it is it
is i think a specialty coming from the
Nordics children and other Scandinavian
country we see really involvement of the
subscribers of the people digging until
their house this is not common you know
the thoughts of you of i would say no
graham do you see change between mean
you have the old monopoly operators the
incumbents holding back a little and
then you have these new upcoming
companies which are reinvesting more do
you see that the incumbents are
investing more now in the future or yes
I mean our forecast assumes that the
incumbents will become quite a bit more
significant in the future than they are
now I mean compared to other regions of
the world the incumbents are actually
relatively uninvolved it but it depends
on the country but overall they're
responsible for something like a third
of the deployment so far we think by
2018 it'll be more like half of the
deployed lines will have been deployed
by the old incumbent telcos but it's
very variable from one country to
another and you know the the situation
in each country differs so in some cases
the driving factor is competition
particularly with cable msos you know as
they start offering higher speed
services the telcos feel like they have
to have something to compete with and
sometimes that means ftth and in other
cases as Roland said it may be
government or you know local
municipalities who are really driving it
who say our city
each fiber and that's the case in many
of the Nordic countries yeah if we if we
look in a broader angle and look outside
Europe we know that the Asians but most
of them we talk about Asian countries
like Hong Kong and Singapore which is
more more or less like Luxembourg which
is more or less like a larger city how
do what happens out there well in terms
of volume it is clear that as yeah
Pacific is really leading the way
because he was the first there were the
first country to deploy those technology
talking about Japan talking about an
South Korea but now country like China
with a huge potential is also deploying
a heavenly fiber to the home so in terms
of volume it is not comparable it is
nearly close to 80 million subscriber in
the zone and we see also on our other
zones with huge potential like Latin
America like Middle East in those
countries it's a kind of leap frog from
very bad technology to the brand new
technologies of fiber can be quite
popular even if it is native at the
moment we believe that the potential is
Eugene in those zone of the world is it
the same ones investing in in fiber the
incumbents or the new actors that
investing fiber in these other areas as
well well in those countries expect
especially in Latin America or Middle
East it is a heavily model incumbents
being a being deploying we see some also
subsidiary liked Almack's for example in
other parts of other of those of the
higher investing but it's mainly driven
by incumbents it is the case also in
Middle East with use deployment in the
UAE for example in Saudi Arabia here we
see mainly doing converse on the driving
seat son or doing combat scene in Europe
too slow are there a little bit lazy
leaning back hanging on to the old
technology not so eager to invest in the
new in the future well good
already pointed out sure that it depends
what you have in house I would say if
you have a good copper like it is the
case in Europe of course you are tempted
to deploy vdsl vectoring because you
have this good copper the situation in
term of install cop is very different
you know the battle of the old so this
is the case in Western Europe am yeah I
think I mean that's me if you look at a
country like Belgium but your belgacom
is the first operator which has
announced commercial plans this year to
deploy vector DC dsl and on their lines
that allows them to provide a guaranteed
service of 70 megabits per second and
you know i mean that's that's a pretty
decent speed to be able to offer to
consumers and probably will take them
quite a long way forward but all this
that's not for a heavy user it is it it
depends I mean it's quite an interesting
question there aren't that many
applications that require more than 70
megamix for saying but having said that
you know I mean there are operators out
there who are actually providing one
gigabit per second services I don't know
what they're being used for but some
people just want to have the highest
speed some people I services sorry some
people like to have a ladder or
something I make the analogy with a
Ferrari you can't drive a Ferrari at the
speeds it's designed for on most roads
but people buy them anyway so it's a
little bit the same with broadband
people want my speed it's like a Rolex
watch I mean yes it shows the same time
it I by the way grandpa another one
gigabit offer yeah we have seen on the
last quarter of last year acceleration
of one gig offer being proposed in
Europe countries larger Switzerland he
also incident in the example even in the
Island of Jersey things are appearing in
France or also so this one gig offer our
popping up now even if it's more
flagship offer for the moment but it's a
good sign of acceleration in terms of
bandwidth proposal is it the demand or
is it because the operators like to
investing the new services I think it's
more marketing trick at the moment but
he can drive also a demand it's also i
mean it's its own nose be able to say we
can
do at least as well as much bandwidth as
the cable operator can do or more
because a lot of the competition is
rivalry between the incumbent telco and
the cable operator and that's where some
of these one gigabit offers are coming
from is there any any I mean you're like
lexicons when it comes to comes the
broadband and fiber out Roli is there
anything we have missed in this
discussion and if they any date I mean
you have so much data anything specific
you want to point out well maybe 22
points what is interesting to be seen in
Europe is that the commercial success is
actually writing I mean the tech upright
the people subscribing to fibre we see a
progression compared to last year so
it's a good point it seems that people
are really believing on the benefit or
fibre to the home another point quite
interesting and here in student is a
good example really thing that to have a
fibre rollout outside of the urban city
involvement of local authorities will be
key co-investment between the players
will be key so there are still things to
be done by the government by the
regulator to allow this kind of action
because it will be needed to other to
reach the goal of the Digital Agenda of
the open comission yes i mean i agree
with roland want one of the issues which
still is not completely resolved in many
countries is the regulatory issue that
the right regulatory environment exists
to encourage operators to invest in fire
because it's a huge investment they need
clarity and they need some consistency
and some assurance that the regulation
is not going to suddenly change and we
haven't quite got there i would say in
many european countries in the european
union in particular so that's one issue
the other issue which i think is
interesting is around the cost to
operate networks that's actually quite
an important driving factor for
deploying ftth we don't have a huge
amount of really good data yet on that
on what the differences between
operating a copper based network and a
fibre network what we know is that it's
quite a lot cheaper
and as that becomes more important and
it probably will become more of an issue
for the legacy operators that might lead
them to deploy FTTH even where there's
not an obvious demand simply because
it's a cheaper network to operate and
they're replacing the old network no I
just you have been around looking at the
event both are the seminars and at the
exhibition hall is there anything
specific you'd like to point out that
our viewers shouldn't miss shouldn't
miss to check out later in the webcast
and streams on the Internet well I think
Mia added the privilege to attend many
of the the counselor Kaufman sir I think
that we really see now a true ecosystem
when they playing fibre-to-the-home in
terms of the passive Network deactive
the content or also to be run in those
network so I'm I quite appreciated this
this show because we can see really the
whole ecosystem progressing and being
more and more mature for a larger fiber
hole out is it much better when you're
in Stockholm than when you have been in
other countries of course this scenario
this morning was wonderful to see the
snow I instruct counsel really
appreciate this you appreciate the snow
you don't have a real line stokoe my
hair I was out six o'clock this morning
to shovel away the snow yeah I mean yeah
I think that you know I mean we are here
in Stockholm the thing that I was most
impressed with listening to is the the
way in which different cities in Sweden
have come together and and created a
consensus around deploying fiber I think
that's very impressive I wish it with
happening in the UK you know we don't we
don't have very much fibers at home in
the UK there are lots of other countries
in Europe where that Swedish approach
you know based on kind of local and
regional pushing towards fiber is
something that's a infrastructure they
have to have I think that's the
direction that many many other
operators she always many other
countries she's going and some of the
data that was presented in some of the
sessions yesterday demonstrated that you
can do that without actually placing a
burden of Taxation on Ed on on citizens
you know the the presentation that was
made by stock AB for example
demonstrated that you know they they
were able to roll out of a fiber network
and make it a you know a cost a profit
Center on the call center so that was
very impressive to me Jay thank you much
for coming it was a pleasure pleasure to
have you here they can keep very very
very much thank you and as you can see
we're still here at the floor and the
people are coming everywhere from from
everywhere to talk about this event and
talk in this event and with me now i
have the ftth council europe president
correct and then i have one of Sweden's
best experts on ipv6 v6 if you say so
yeah Patrick felt strong from net nod
thank you so what's your impressions of
this event so far well I'm very happy
with the event all in all for me it's
very important to see the members being
happy listening to them exhibit in
meeting their potential customers and
existing customers here and they seem to
be happy and I'm also very happy to see
a lot of the European and Nordic
stakeholders here visiting it was
actually one of my concerns nordic
countries are a bit far off or people
tend to see it that way and the
traveling here it's also mature market
could be and I quite some steps to take
and well I'm just happy to see that
wasn't the case and they're actually
here being very active taking part of
the discussions meeting their exhibitors
and everything were you ever afraid of I
mean inviting all the people from Europe
to Sweden to your hometown to show you
mean you have been around Europe talking
about Sweden Sweden so good swedish
those this and that and then and the
imagine of everyone coming here and they
were like
that's old well we've seen that I think
actually we see see it that way our
selves we think that everybody knows the
thing we know and that isn't the case i
think i mentioned that also in in my
opening speech that it's it's not old
news it's actually the thing that people
are facing now in other parts of Europe
and no I wasn't scared of it I was proud
taking them here and writing them to our
country to see what we have done and
even though we have done a lot we still
have a lot more today we can't just rest
assure that we have done everything we
can we need to say take further steps
need to be more active even though we
see a lot of projects and we have the
business models maybe things aren't
settled and we need to take the race and
the match to get there yeah and it was
abroad Patrick it yeah yeah okay turn to
the very inner into the market into
everything here he can gives his
perspective Patrick you I mean you're
traveling around the world almost all
the time your appt at the event that
like this yeah almost every week is
there anything special that struck you
on this event first of all this is as
you say I travel around to events like
this but very often as a as a speaker or
moderator at this event I was only
participant sit in the audience like
both days of course yes I grabbed a
microphone at one of the 10 de vence but
it could not really like resist but to
be a participant anybody see what the
conference was like and and I'm actually
very very happy that someone I'd like
the questions that are well ECU's that
are closest to my heart actually start
to get discussed and I got a lot of
questions from from individuals and
organizations that are that from my
perspective have have been a little bit
confused on for example what you mean by
open what do you mean by like it equal
access what you mean by those terms and
I have been waiting for years and years
and years to actually start have a
discussion about it because I think
there are disagreements but you don't
know what the disagreements are unless
you really start to talk about the
details and I see that started here I'm
really happy so are we in sweden in
forefront of these discussions or are
there other countries in forefront of
the discussions other countries are
further ahead than
and that is for example just because we
use terms like open network and
broadband without defining them and
there are specifically two very
different different kinds of fiber
networks in Sweden one where the dark
fiber is a wholesale product is
available in equal terms to anyone that
we'd like to access it and then with the
other model where where you have one and
only one player that is activating the
fiber and you can get only what is
normally called bitstream access and
these two models are so completely
different in different business models
so I think we have made a mistake in
Sweden to talk about these two as if
they were the same thing so that is not
so we have something to learn from the
others this case absolutely only on the
other hand the specifically the
bitstream project that we have with what
we call communications operator that's
something that they don't have in other
parts of Europe which might be good for
them in certain cases but from my
perspective it still requires the
ability to access the dark fiber as a
wholesale product like in Stockholm for
example this new cab which of course is
talked about quite a lot here can you
just explain the word communique phone
super otter for the audience what we
talked about usually when we try to
translate it from our perspective it's
an aggregator of services and you don't
see that actually well they tried it in
the Netherlands they tried it somewhere
else but it's not an established model
outside sweden outside norway say oh
well i think it also it's a case of
maturity and customer demand business
models we've done this for 10 years in
Sweden we had to take steps further to
to full of the the needs and the the
regulatory regulatory frameworks we had
here with open access networks going
down in the value chain with the network
owners this gave the opportunity for
someone to step into the market and
aggregate the content that was available
and i think that was sexually their
kick-starting of it i think this event
actually highlighted highlighted a lot
of business model discussions where are
we and why are we where we are and
I'm happy it happened here actually and
I think it's the only possibility to
happen in the Nordic skis it's so
established and people come here to
focus on it and open up the discussion
on the Flores party present also the
moderators were very prepared to do that
from the stage and I think that was one
of the huge impacts actually of the
event the theme of the event is a
brighter future and we'll talk a lot
about dark fiber that seems is that a
brighter future Patrick you have we seen
the brighter future here yeah I think so
for example and what I would I sometimes
talk about the the the dis equations in
some parts of Sweeney which is bad as
Koren says that's an indication we are
further ahead than the rest of Europe
but we need to learn and fix those
mistakes if there are mistakes and then
help the rest of the Europe to to sort
of speed up Foster and not redo all the
mistakes we had another thing i would
like to point out was regarding brighter
future has to do with all the statements
about openness and and they fight for an
open Internet both from a business
standpoint and computation issue but
also from the freedom of Rights you from
a human rights perspective that we heard
from the IQ Minister and also the
Foreign Minister yesterday they made
very strong statements why sweden have a
view that an open internet will give a
bright future so also from long-term
sustainability standpoint from the
society I think there were very clear
signs from the political level now of
course all of us have to deliver
including politicians but at least we
have some statements to refer to I also
think it was very refreshing both
yesterday morning in the big opening and
this morning with the keynote speakers
they old addressed several topics like
open Internet fiber deployments we need
it faster we needed more all these
statements in such an event and they
were really strong messaging around it
and that really not only helps us but it
proves that the existing of our
organization is vital and we need to be
there to further support and push for
these messages we need to be there for
the local governments for the local
policymakers for the operators for
the market and the end consumer and I
take that with me after this event and
we will definitely try to focus much
more on that for the coming conferences
and the new emerging markets on the
eastern side of Europe yeah it's these
people here from 84 86 nations yes it
four nations and it's really impressive
it's crazy but I mean can everybody do
the level i mean we're talking in the
swedish level and somebody maybe is from
a country at this level can they meet
somewhere I think they can there is a
balance and it's an exchange of
experiences and that is also what we're
here for it to exchange knowledge
exchange experiences we had the pre
workshop day with a Nordic workshop a
whole day it was a full room where
people from all over the world who
signed up could come there and ask
questions what does a lesson learned
what I doing now what are the next steps
what are the implications the obstacles
what are you doing to get over them you
know really in-depth discussions from
operators to contractors to whatever you
can think of and I heard so many good
comments about that workshop and I think
we need to learn to do this more to
really exchange our knowledge not only
about the Nordic and Swedish market but
all in all and of course we try to focus
a bit extra where we actually have our
conference but for sure there are people
or nations who do more than others and I
think there is definitely a learning
curve for us to use that yes also so to
bring back to you what what can't you
said about so many issues been discussed
if you think about what
fiber-to-the-home what the term means it
talks about the actual access to the
household should be fiber that's
actually very very tiny and very very
narrow topic but if you then look at
what actually I've been discussed here
everything from human rights issues what
is discussed in the United Nations to
business models for pan-european and
panworld ISPs service models TVs new
kind of gaming like whatever that I'm
surprised in a positive way over how how
broad the topics were yeah what would
struck me is that
the it's very much talking about
infrastructure we had a discussion here
about yesterday about the internet of
everything I think the topic was and all
and over and over again we fell down to
the dark fiber to the infrastructure
issues instead of talking services I
think that's interesting and fascinating
it sounds so simple you need an
infrastructure but it clearly shows how
important it is to get it right from the
start to invest in it once and to do it
right from the beginning and to really
make sure that you have a secure
connection to the household or to the
end consumer whatever it is businesses
households public buildings that is what
it's all about and we don't see that
happening why it's very poor not there
yet it happens in small scale lots of
projects everywhere but it's small scale
and we need to scale it up we need to
push it out throughout Europe because
that is the only way to be a sustainable
society sustainable you're competitive
and attractive to to the industry so I
think first of all people need to
understand that they need sort of fiber
new kind of infrastructure and they
don't know that until they understand
for example that the copper has too much
water in it or damaged it cannot be used
when you have a question or replacing it
or do something else that is one time
when it when it might hurt the second
the second thing of course is when you
need lots of capacity and you sort of
need need some need some fiber but then
in the then you start to do the
investments throughout a fiber and then
you understand wait a second this is an
investment that actually lost for 48
years and it's pretty darn expensive and
for the society it's better to share
that so wait a second are we coming into
infrastructure sharing and the whole
wholesale discussion and that those are
sort of new business models that needs
to be discussed but they do not get
discussed unless it hurts so as long as
you can use the existing infrastructure
areas you don't really have to talk
about I take a bridge over between
Sweden and Denmark for example it was
sort of discussed that you really needed
it but he was not really built until it
really hurt right so some of these
things are I think or discussed now
regarding
just because now we are in a sweet spot
in time when people really see a need
for a new infrastructure and we need to
end we are all trying from our different
angles to find the best way of actually
getting that is established because if
we're going to get fiber or new
infrastructure to every place in Europe
where we do have electricity that takes
some time sweden I think it took 150
years to let get electricity to every
household and we are trying to do fiber
to the same places in 20 years is it
that big difference I think so first of
all I think being is possible mats first
of all the important thing is to
remember we can we know that we can have
fiber to every place where we have
electricity in some parts of the world
luckily not Europe they're working with
a problem getting fiber and I internets
two places which do not have electricity
we don't have that problem here but to
start with we should not say oh we
cannot have fiber over there because
it's so far away but wait a second we
have electricity over there so it is
possible I guess there is much money to
do to earn from getting fiber out there
we saw a Swedish report just last week
about care of elder people where the
price price of taking care of them fell
down so much that it would finance the
tota total fiber out role of LG sweden
next ten years or something and that is
just the beginning I think looking at
the eHealth perspective of course that's
the focus for many of our municipalities
they have a huge aging population we
need to modernize our way to take care
of their Lee and people who are in the
healthcare system and that is just one
of the all the areas that we see
applications Cummings and big savings to
be made and I think there is a big I
shouldn't say earning but a big upside
for the municipalities for the public
society as a whole to look at what they
can effective eyes and push out there
and make more cuz they are usually the
ones that invest in the in the
infrastructure from the beginning they
should actually make use of it better
and I think we're taking the first steps
we see the first reports coming out and
that is it started like a year ago we
could see the socio-economic
benefits coming up as a hot topic and
this is a spinoff from that and we will
see much more coming for the coming
years and I am nervous about for example
we take Sweden if I remember if i
remember correctly report from the other
week say that Sweden has the highest
urbanization at the moment in the world
that people move to cities and we cannot
sustain that stockholm cannot sustain
that we have been discussing the product
of Zeus and I think don't know how many
years so so so tall so it's also on a
macro scale the organization that has
happened bc disease must be stopped in
somewhere and that means that we need to
decentralize a little bit more and that
is also that requires communication as
well yeah yeah so we're already in the
afternoon this is the last day of the
event guess you have been around for a
while looking at the different parts of
the different seminars and different
parts of this exhibition is there
anything special you would like to point
out as the best success story or the
best thing of the what I hear from the
exhibitors the best thing they
appreciate with aveda Congress this year
is the facility and the way it's built
up you have lots of spaces to meet and
to discuss you have a spacey area around
the booths so the customers can come and
delegates can come and go and you can
really show them what you have in your
booth and its really appreciated with
the seminars and the dark area with the
Nordic lounge and everything I think
that also is a very nice theme that
combines with all packages and listening
to the delegates they really like the
way they can talk to talk to the
speakers listening to the seminar is
walking around get impressions to bring
back and they also know how to to get
more information from us in each topic
and that is an improvement from our side
this is also an improvement for our side
the first time we do the streaming we
try to share more of the knowledge we
have and the content we produced during
these days so this is a important first
step in many ways for us in as a
conference organizer yes I'm at home
yes no no this is actually as Koren said
the spacious areas a lot of places hit a
lot of lot of locations to have
discussions i think that skin navy
launched i think you had meetings there
all afternoon yesterday so so so some
people say oh it's so far to walk but
that's actually positive thing I've been
to so many conference where it's crowded
it's noisy you cannot sit down anywhere
it's it's a pain and this is relaxing I
see people walking around being relaxed
and then of course internet access here
works so when you when you when you're
not going to session I can do my day job
as well so so I'm actually feeling
relaxed I'm not I don't have to wait two
days so I'm read email like piling up
and bad conscience it's actually taking
care of I'm really glad to have had you
here thank you very much coming now
thank you thank you pleasure thank you
so much and that's all for this Web cast
will be back later on at quarter to four
thank you so much for watching us
you